[Música]
pasamos a las noticias de salud y para
ello me acompaña Mara Romero salamar Un
saludo para usted Buenos días Ángela con
los buenos días hablemos de la
Organización Mundial de la Salud y que
está buscando un nuevo tratado para
hacer frente a futuras pandemias al
parecer seguimos sin estar listos no
seguimos sin estar listos Pero al menos
están dando unas conversaciones que
quizás nos podrán ayudar a largo plazo a
estar mejor para el futuro esta semana
está reunida la junta de la Organización
Mundial de la Salud y se hizo público
Este primer borrador para una potencial
tratado Vamos a repasar los principales
puntos una de las medidas más concretas
de reservar el 20% de vacunas y
tratamientos que se compren en los
países más ricos para poder darlos a
países que tengan además dificultad en
acceder a este tipo Pues de bienes no de
vacunas tratamientos todo un 10% sería
donación y un 10% sería vendido digamos
a un precio negociado amigable también
levantar los derechos de propiedad
intelectual de estas vacunas
tratamientos todo lo que sirva para
combatir la pandemia durante el tiempo
que dure la emergencia sanitaria también
se pide más transparencia en los
contratos públicos con las Industrias
farmacéuticas y que se hagan nuevos
acuerdos para compartir la información
sobre los patógenos que sean de riesgo
con más rapidez Estos son algunos de los
puntos que se conocen hasta ahora el
debate alrededor de la propiedad
intelectual de las vacunas que hemos
visto muchísimo en estos años continúa
presente qué es lo que opina la
industria farmacéutica amar sí ha sido
uno de los grandes tira y aflojas de
esta pandemia del covid-19 se llegó a
levantar temporalmente pues las patentes
de propiedad intelectual pero solo fue
después de largas conversaciones después
de que las farmacéuticas y hubieran
ganado beneficios millonarios pues con
la venta de las vacunas que
desarrollaron muy rápidamente y cuando
la brecha de vacunación no entre los
países con Poder adquisitivo y los que
no lo tienen ya era muy amplia en
general la industria farmacéutica lo que
defiende es que estos incentivos no de
beneficios que pueden hacer vendiendo
sus productos es lo que los hace
desarrollar tan rápido y ponerle tantos
recursos a desarrollar las vacunas
contra el covid 19 por ejemplo o contra
lo que sea que tengamos que hacerle
frente al futuro escuchemos las
declaraciones del director de la
federación internacional de
farmacéuticos
la respuesta innovadora de la industria
farmacéutica al covid 19 demuestra que
un ambiente de vibrante innovación
combinado con un acceso rápido de los
patógenos y con las colaboraciones
público privadas son esenciales para una
respuesta afectiva a la pandemia debemos
construir sobre lo que fue bien en la
pandemia actual sigamos por esa línea
qué fue bien en la pandemia pues es un
buen momento no para hacer esta
recapitulación y este balance porque
precisamente la Organización Mundial de
la Salud decía que estamos ya en un
punto de inflexión en esta crisis
sanitaria es cierto y tiene que
reconocer que hubo una gran rapidez a la
hora de desarrollar test para detectar
el covid 19 también las vacunas
distintas vacunas además que se
complementaron entre sí como lo estamos
viendo ahora con los esquemas de
vacunación pero es cierto que fue la
primera vez que se requirió una
coordinación y una cooperación
internacional a nivel sanitario tan alta
y en ese sentido podemos decir que fue
un fracaso bastante grande y no son mis
palabras son las palabras del director
de la Organización Mundial de la Salud
de
recordando solo algunos de los episodios
más oscuros alrededor de las vacunas del
cómic 19 recordemos cuando se donaron a
países africanos vacunas que estaban a
punto de caducar por ejemplo covax que
era el esquema internacional destinado a
repartir más igualitariamente estos
fármacos no logró ni más o menos
aproximadamente la mitad de su objetivo
o el momento de omicron no se pide
precisamente rapidez a la hora de
detectar patógenos Sudáfrica avisó muy
tempranamente de una variante que podía
ser de riesgo como después se demostró
que era y la respuesta internacional fue
cerrar fronteras cerrar cualquier tipo
de canal de ayuda es decir que en ese
sentido Es cierto que si bien hubo
muchos beneficios para las farmacéuticas
y hubo un avance Pues significativo en
términos de investigación y de ciencia a
nivel social tenemos pocos logros que
celebrar qué vergüenza Sí la verdad es
que sí estas crisis sacan lo mejor pero
también lo peor lo peor de nosotros qué
dicen las organizaciones de la sociedad
civil Pues precisamente para intentar
solventar ese tipo de cosas apoyan la
propuesta del tratado que está
impulsando la Organización Mundial de la
Salud y también piden aprender de los
errores escuchemos
la mayoría de los países no estaban
preparados para el covid 19 y la mayoría
Siguen sin estar listos contra algún
brote futuro no habrá excusa para una
ausencia continuada de preparación
después de estos tres terribles años
estar preparados significa estar listo
para responder recuperarse y aprender
lecciones para la próxima ocasión
la propuesta de la Cruz Roja estábamos
escuchando su secretario general ahora
es que todos los países aumentan al
menos un 1% su gasto en la salud pública
repasando algunas de las cifras en la
región latinoamericana pero también en
España vemos que los países que por
ejemplo México sólo gasta un 6% de su
pib en inversión en salud pública
Bolivia 7,8 Colombia casi 9% y España
uno de los países europeos que también
tenemos aquí para comparar más del 10%,
sin embargo eso no quita que España
fuera por ejemplo uno de los países más
golpeados por la pandemia que tuviera
una que se evidenciara que faltaba pues
muchos recursos para hacerle frente a
los problemas que puso eso nos da pues
una idea de que todos los países tienen
mucho camino todavía por recorrer para
terminar quería recordar además que
Bueno estamos hablando de este borrador
que se ha presentado ahora pero se
calcula que no se aprobará hasta
mediados de 2024 precisamente Pues
porque hay muchos países sobre todo los
países de menos recursos que impulsan a
favor del tratado no que piden que se
haga así pero luego también hay muchos
otros países o el lobby de la industria
farmacéutica que influyen muchos
gobiernos que van a intentar negociar o
limar algunas de estas diferencias es
decir que tenemos todavía mucho debate
por delante antes de tener una guía no o
un tratado que nos diga cómo tenemos que
responder a las futuras pandemias Y eso
sin pensar en que funcione exactamente
si ni siquiera haberlo probado pues mar
Muchísimas gracias a usted por la
actualización y los datos que no son
reveladores son vergonzosos y hay que
seguirlos mencionando hay que seguirlos
mencionando sobre todo para no
olvidarlos en el futuro Muchas gracias
gracias